à l'ouverture de cette grande surface de
l'ouest à l'entrée du supermarché des
jeunes et leurs parents se font prendre
en photo je vais dans le sud de la
france pour faire leur métier quoique
pour passer un crp boucherie dans le
région sud de région paca de la force
peut pas de calais le port rencontre à
la botte l'agencé ap le shac
dans la région paca pour être apprenti
boucher louise fait ainsi partie des dix
sept nouveaux contrats d'apprentissage
du groupe casino a 24 ans et père de
famille cette formation
professionnalisante est une opportunité
c'était pour
un recrutement des employés du service
sur paris j'étais attiré par lui et la
grande distribution
et puis depuis quitté l'école qui ait
jamais eu l'occasion de vraiment
travailler dans la grande distribution à
programme son intérim est là bas sinon
continuer de pouvoir continuer en 2010
qu'en distribution des diplômes en vente
ça me permet d prochaine dans la grande
distribution et fait la vente en même
temps elle avoue j'ai 24 ans je joue
ma dernière chance de pouvoir réussir et
que ici c'est humain là à réussir et
casino s'engage justement à la fin de
contraint avec l'obtention du diplôme de
nous garder dans l'entreprise depuis
sept ans 72 réunionnais comme loïc ont
réussi leur insertion professionnelle
par cette mobilité et ce jour là les
futurs boulangers pâtissiers bouchers
viennent récupérer leurs promesses
d'embûches et leur billet d'avion aller
la session a besoin de coup pouce la
mobilité est un vrai coup de pouce
l'opérateur que nous avons le cnam qui
fait un travail reconnu aujourd'hui
implanté en métropole avec des
conseillers d'insertion dans toute la
france qui peuvent rester en lien avec
le jeune les parents et je m'adresse
aujourd'hui aux parents au fond un jeune
il réussit quand le parent n'a confiance
en lui quand le parent izia lilla papp
secoue la grille un coup de coin qui
photo matt et revient montpetit
marmaille parce que voilà non si si le
parent lui donne la possibilité de se
dire que la vie ça n'est pas un long
fleuve tranquille que il tombe mais sur
la tombe trois fois on relève quatre
fois eh ben je crois que le jeune aura
la possibilité de réussite et au fond de
la salle les yeux rougis par l'émotion
la maman de loïc capéran
il va revenir plus fort oui pas grandit
aussi en même temps difficiles et la
maison ses parents pour les jeunes
réunionnais le parcours d'insertion est
loin d'être facile aussi le travail
collectif de tous les partenaires du
cnls armes tels que le pôle emploi les
missions locales ou encore le rsm a
permet de préparer au mieux notre
jeunesse
à partir du moment où ils arrivent au
rsma on distingue les gens où on
souhaite distinguer les gens qui perd
qui veulent partir mobilité et à partir
de ces gens là il faut les préparer
parce que c'est une longue démarche
comme comme on a pu le constater et
parce qu'il y en a qui sont pas prévu
qu'ils sont trop jeunes ou qui ont
peut-être pas pensé à ce projet là donc
les jeunes on les prépare et ceux qui
partent en mobilité
normalement c'est ce qu'ils sont et ça
représente
je dirais ans aujourd'hui 25% de notre
installation on est effectivement dans
une opération réussie d'insertion
professionnelle dans laquelle l'ensemble
des partenaires des acteurs de cette
logique d'insertion professionnelle se
sont donné la main ont travaillé en
parfaite intelligence nous faut réussir
ce pourquoi d'ailleurs ils sont payés
ils sont missionnés réussir formidable
personne mobilité
sourire tranche papaye pour ces jeunes
acteurs de leur avenir
le coup de pouce d'une arme qui résident
dans le billet d'avion une prime
d'installation ou encore une allocation
d'arrivée un paquet du tuc n'arme
contrepartie d'un engagement
professionnel sérieux au moment des
photos souvenirs
un salarié du groupe regardez mu la
nouvelle promotion
aujourd'hui directeur de magasin à saint
pierre il a commencé comme eux j'ai
commencé en groupe comme seul ce
nettoyage et là que le groupe a donné la
chance de briller quelques femmes ont
parfois donc j'étais chef de rayon
manager département
directeur aujourd'hui je suis
autodidacte quand j'ai commencé
d'entreprise la troupe et il m'a permis
de grandir
bien sûr avec du travail voilà c'est ça
la clé exactement ce qu'est la russie
ce travail travail travail pendant ce
temps loïc et sur internet pour
découvrir cette nouvelle ville sensible
future politique est là tu vas le
chercher sur internet
est ce que ça te plaît comme comme lieu
oui ça me plaît s'il ya la mer donc
c'est bon vous serez pas trop de donner
le coup de pouce utile à une jeunesse
qui veut se prendre en main et le succès
de tous les partenaires du conseil
départemental tendre ainsi une main en
espérant que l'autre fera demain avancer
la ligne mais après j'ai toute ma
famille dit à moi maman par par ma
boutique
principe y étouffer tout ce qu'il faut
pour elle seule